no inside fiestas come car tester tanju
gench says the first Ford Mustang hit us
streets in 1964 and went on to become an
icon now half a century later German
customers can finally order one directly
from Ford not just through importers
tanju is sure his colleagues are jealous
that he's getting to test this special
car listen to that sound he says he
thinks it's wonderful and so does andre
and he's not just horsing around and
rape takes advantage of the opportunity
to put the mustang with its five-liter
v8 engine through its paces
yeah good he laments that American cars
generally aren't so good on curves but
Andrew says the Mustang rounds this one
without a problem the cars built for
sporty driving on curves and on
straightaways by ethnic Norfolk guarding
aboard the rocker switches in the center
console allow you to adjust the steering
as well as the responsiveness of the
engine the Mustang lets drivers choose
between a sporty ride or a more
comfortable one while he knows that
tanju must be chomping at the bit to get
his pony car back andre still wants to
hold on to the reins a while longer
you
and the Mustang is certainly priced
right at just forty thousand euros in
Germany it's the only car with a v8
engine to be had for that amount and
that price includes almost everything
the leather steering wheel climate
control and the sink to voice-activated
infotainment system so there are few
optional extras available in contrast at
299 g/km the car produces a lot of co2
emissions
oh one meanwhile tanju is reading the
mustang GT press kit and he's impressed
with its 5 liters of cubic capacity the
v8 engine generates a whopping 530
newton meters of torque sending the car
to a top speed of 250 kilometres an hour
it must be fun to drive my shona
thanagar with Andre who is driving it
says that at engine speeds of up to
3,000 rpms the Mustang cruises along but
exceeds 3,000 rpms and it's like you're
riding a horse on steroids racing
through the Prairie with 417 other wild
horses urging you on fear did you ain't
on a phone impression
as a disciple Andrew says the Mustangs
transmission is also something else
gearshift travel is nice and short but
also pretty not cheap you really have to
put some muscle into switching gears he
says that in any other car that'd be a
big miners spit here it's fitting as it
makes you feel that the Mustangs are car
for really tough men and women food a
Mustang is an artificial steinhardt am
in order for now start the Mustangs
design has changed greatly over the
years but now Ford has gone back to the
roots Dalai estimates Andrew says the
first Mustang had an iconic design in
recent years Ford has revived it to
great success it's immediately
recognizable even to kids he thinks Ford
has done such a good job with the new
model that it merits a closer look the
Mustang was named after the p-51 Mustang
fighter plane still it was the galloping
wild horse that became the American
sports cars emblem although originally
conceived as a woman's car the Mustang
has developed into a model that
fascinates men and women alike this fast
fat Kupe in particular really turns
heads
inside apart from the occasional bit of
leather the trim is made of plastic
rather than aluminium buyers who want
real leather Recaro bucket seats will
need to shell out 1800 euros more hit
the start button and the powerful v8
springs to life missed and I almost
forgot his bags he says GT stands for
Gran Turismo a car suitable for long
trips and in spite of its fastback shape
the Mustang can hold lots of cargo key
there's a tiny design so what's his
overall impression of the car
yeah gold as often mentioned he says
with its v8 engine the Mustang isn't a
car for sensible drivers this test car
guzzled 16 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers no wonder was such a huge
engine but you get that great sound the
fans want a vivre that the Mustang gives
you all for a super basement price it's
madness you can't imagine anyone not
having fun in this car except when you
need to fill up the tank which reminds
him for tank stellar a port for tanks
tether being the nice guy he is Android
brings the Mustang back to tanju without
disrupting his beauty sleep maybe now's
the time to mention that the Mustang is
also available with a 4-cylinder
EcoBoost engine which reduces fuel
consumption to eight liters per 100
kilometers oh those are endless now that
the Mustangs back tanju is thrilled that
he can finally start his test drive he's
ready to roll but unfortunately the gas
tanks empty